hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
another month approaches and with it
comes more of those brand new games June
is historically a month with few
releases due to everyone looking forward
to e3 but there are a handful of games
that deserve your attention here are
eight new games coming in June 2019
[Music]
without a doubt the biggest game of the
month is Crash Team Racing nitro fueled
a kart racer which dare I say it is
actually worthy enough to rival Mario
Kart
I know strong word strong words indeed
back in 1999 the original naughty dog
game showed us what the cast of Crash
Bandicoot do with their time off over
the years multiple developers iterated
upon CTR and now 20 years later
everything has been perfected racing
into your friends and family with fast
paced arcade action with varied pickups
to turn last place into first place
there are two versions of the game the
base game and the nitrous-oxide Edition
which adds extra character skins themes
avatars and early access to nitrous
oxides character but don't be fooled
into thinking he's unavailable in the
base game he's there he's completely
unlockable and come on the main reason
to grind through the adventure mode is
to unlock that exact character with your
own blood sweat and tears and the
occasional destroyed controller to Crash
Team Racing nitro fueled releases on
June 21st on ps4 Xbox one and switch
costing about a third less than a
typical triple-a title so about twenty
dollars twenty euros twenty pounds less
than you'd usually pay
are you a fan of isometric role-playing
games like Baldur's Gate or diad blow
well there's a new game to grab your
attention
Warhammer Kaos Bane dumbness a good
title Warhammer videogames are usually
turn based strategy Affairs but this
time the law and mythology of Warhammer
is fully realized in a RPG glory the
fantasy world and many of its iconic
locations can be found within chaos Bane
such as Prague or nul how you get to
these is another question though
allowing frustrated hack and slash
button pressing madness or a more
considered approach of character focus
on skills and abilities there are four
character classes to choose from each
with unique traits warhammer chaos Bane
may just be the RPG you're looking for
releasing on June the 1st on ps4 Xbox
one and the PC the Elder Scrolls online
has quietly been building an
astronomically huge open world
consistently evolving and growing the
DLCs and updates continue to drop in the
season of the Dragon and this time is
elsewhere my personal highlight is the
new class the necromancer I'm
legitimately downloading the game again
after trying to give it up before this
update to take the power of the undead
and bend it to your whims oh oh yes get
me involved in that just in case this
seems a little out of the blue
the Elder Scrolls online is an MMO RPG a
massively multiplayer online
role-playing game if you've played
Skyrim imagine that with dozens upon
dozens of other people it's been up and
running since about 2014 so in those
five years it has changed a great deal
and definitely improved so if you do own
it it might be time to have another look
now well back to the dlc elsewhere well
elsewhere in elsewhere we will be
fighting dragons again but don't expect
for these to be fresh road into oblivion
to take down one of these beasts you'll
need friends because teamwork makes the
dream work elsewhere also gives you an
insight into the world of the Khajiit
you know those big [ __ ] cat people but
just don't say that to their faces the
other Scrolls online elsewhere drops on
June 4th on ps4 Xbox one and PC
June is a time where we begin to see
those annual sports titles pop up yet
again starting with racing games this
month f1 2019 and MotoGP 19 want your
attention both have received huge
updates MotoGP in particular after a
stuttering last few years MotoGP 19 adds
all new AI so don't expect your
opponents to be as easy to beat this
time around
historical challenges are also here
allowing us to play as our heroes from
yesteryear reliving their
accomplishments f1 20:19 on the other
hand has introduced yet more retro and
historic vehicles to their rosters but
it also looks and feels so much more
like the TV spectacle which really sets
us apart from other racing games the
replays the commentary that just the
overall visuals have continued to
improve and add to the immersion and on
top of that the career mode is said to
have even more depth and customization
I'm not sure what that actually means
but it does sound good
MotoGP is the first to release on June
the 6th with f1 2019
crashing into stars on June 28th both
games release on ps4 Xbox one and PC
with MotoGP having a switch edition -
there's a strange phenomenon which sees
great games completely missed by some
regions in the world for example God of
War doesn't sell very well in Japan
weird isn't it well that works both ways
in the West one of the greatest game
series of the last 15 years is missed by
many the Yakuza series
well that series has a spin-off dropping
this month judgment which is an
exclusive ps4 title judgment is a
third-person action-adventure title set
in the Japanese criminal underworld we
will play as a private detective who
attempts to understand the serial killer
leaving clues after each murder
the fighting remains the main cross over
from the Yakuza series with multiple
fighting styles to beat 10 bells of out
of anyone who looks at you funny this is
a whole new story although set in the
world of Yakuza it does not require any
previous game knowledge be careful
though this could be the one game which
makes you love Yakuza and there are 15
games in that series so far just waiting
to take up your
time judgment has many perfect scores
over in Japan let's see what happens
when it hits our shores exclusively on
ps4 on June 25th let's look at a horror
game the sinking city set in a small
fishing village in the 1920s we follow
yet another private investigator as he
looks into the visions of people who
visit this town this is inspired by HP
Lovecraft if you didn't study him at
school then know that he wrote horror
fiction inventing grotesque and
downright disgusting beasts probably the
most well known is the Cthulhu like an
dragon octopus thing it's it's hard to
explain you need to see it expect to see
all kinds of Lovecraftian abominations
in the sinking city which tries to merge
old Silent Hill games with the more
modern approach of outlast to scare you
into submission expect to be unsure what
is real and what's an hallucination
the sinking city hits shelves on June
27th on ps4 PC and Xbox one
[Music]
back in 1993 there was a game which was
as big as Street Fighter it's name was
Samurai Shodown over the next 15 years
it slowly drifted away but after a
10-year hiatus it's back acting as a
reboot to the series 2019 Samurai
Shodown it's all about weapon based
one-on-one action and feels a great deal
like modern Street Fighter games while
keeping what made it unique in the 90s
arcades it looks stunning amazing and if
you're old or you have a great respect
for gaming history
seeing samurai shodown back again is a
welcome sight indeed the story takes us
through what happened between the
original title and showdown 5 but once
again you do not need prior knowledge
even the most dedicated fan has
forgotten what happened 26 years ago oh
my word I feel a hold anyway there we
have it my 8 picks for the month of June
2019 what floats your boat I'm gonna
give Elder Scrolls online another go and
maybe jump back into Crash Team Racing
but what about you I'd love to know your
thoughts so check them in the comments
below I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a bloody pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]